-Thank you very much, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much
for being here.
We have a great show
for you tonight.
Bruce Springsteen
is here in studio.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I saw Bruce backstage.
I said,
"Thank you so much for being
here on the first night
of Hanukkah."
And Bruce said,
[ As Springsteen ] "Jimmy, for
the last time, I'm not Jewish."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, things aren't
going too well
for President Trump lately,
but that didn't stop him
from throwing a party
last night. Watch this.
-Overnight, President Trump
hosting a Hanukkah party
at the White House using the
holiday gathering to once again
falsely claim
he can still win the election.
[ Laughter ]
Ah, yes, the festival of lies.
Even the dreidel was looking at
Trump like,
"Damn, this guy spins
more than I do."
[ Laughter ]
I like how everyone whipped out
their phones
to record Trump
like it was a drunken fight
in a Waffle House. Like,
"Oh, this is going to go viral.
This is going to get some hits."
It's probably good that Trump
talked about the election.
I feel like him winging
the story of Hanukkah
might have been worse.
It's like,
[ As Trump ] "For eight nights,
Jewish Santa would visit
all the good little Kushners."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Speaking of the White House,
I read that once Trump
moves out,
officials are going to disinfect
the whole building
before Biden moves in.
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
I have a feeling this is going
to be necessary
with or without COVID.
[ Laughter ]
There's a half-eaten Baconator
between the cushions here.
"Turn on the black light.
Good God! Oh, my --"
-Eww!
[ Laughter ]
-"My retinas are burning!
Oh, my --"
Biden's going to be the first
president to be sworn in,
then spend the next week
crashing at a La Quinta.
Apparently, the CDC told Biden
it would be safer
if he just moved
into a bowling shoe.
That doesn't sound -- That
doesn't sound right, does it?
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Biden,
I heard that he might take
an Amtrak train
to his inauguration,
which is slightly different than
what other presidents have done.
That brings us to our new
educational segment called
"Presidential Inaugurations:
Betcha Didn't Know!"
-Joe Biden might travel
to his inauguration by Amtrak,
but betcha didn't know
Jimmy Carter
traveled to his inauguration
by shooting himself
out of a cannon.
♪♪
This has been
"Presidential Inaugurations:
Betcha Didn't Know!"
-Yeah, it's amazing.
I didn't know any of that.
Listen to this --
a pharmaceutical company
had to issue a recall after
two of their drugs got mixed up.
Let's see which ones they were.
-There is a recall this morning
after a drug
used to treat depression
somehow got bottled up
and sent out
with the generic form of Viagra!
[ Laughter ]
-People knew something was up
when, well...
-Hey!
-...something was up.
All right? Ah, come on.
[ Cymbals playing ]
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the people in depression
commercials were like,
"Why do I have the sudden urge
to sit in an outdoor bathtub?"
[ Laughter ]
Samsung just announced its new
110-inch microLED TV,
and it costs about $155,000.
Yep, so now you have
a 110-inch TV playing
while you scroll through
Instagram on your phone.
[ Laughter ]
Can you lower that?
And finally, I saw that Jay-Z
just launched
his own premium brand of weed
called Monogram.
It must be good.
Today, Jay-Z was like,
"I got two problems and forgot
the other 97!"
You know, some things happen
to you in life,
you just go, "Oh, my gosh,
I love that
that just happened
because you just
made me so happy."
Well, last night, we just got
home from doing our show,
and everyone just started
sending me texts and they go,
"Dude, Dionne Warwick
just tweeted at you."
[ Laughter ]
So Dionne Warwick is on Twitter
now, and she's like owning.
She's running Twitter right now.
-Yes.
-And it's so fun. And it's her.
And she tweeted,
"Does anybody know if
Jimmy Fallon will be doing
the Christmas Sweaters countdown
this year?
I love those wretched things."
[ Laughter ]
Dionne Warwick.
I flipped out,
and then I tweeted back to her,
and then she tweeted
back to me again.
-What?
-Yeah. And then I tweeted
back to her again.
And then I guess...
Did you send her a playlist?
-Oh, she got that?
-Dude, she got that and said,
"A playlist from Questlove
and a sweater from Jimmy Fallon.
I'm a happy lady, I can go to
bed happy" or something.
I'm like,
"You are the greatest."
My dad...
I called my dad
after that happened
because she performed
on his aircraft carrier,
the USS Constellation
in 1968 in San Diego.
And trust me, I've heard
this story my whole life.
And that's the whole story.
But I think he saw her even
backstage and just said
how nice he was
and all this stuff.
So we've always been fans.
And my dad said,
"I took a photo,"
and it's so great.
This is so my dad.
So I go, "Yeah, you have a photo
of Dionne Warwick performing?"
And this is 1968.
So it's one of those cameras
that have the cube flash,
the spinner.
So this is my dad's photo,
he says, of Dionne Warwick
performing on his...
[ Laughter ]
That is his photo of
Dionne Warwick,
and it was cool.
I mean, I have photos like this,
too, at concerts where I'm like,
"Oh, my gosh,
I'll never forget it."
But he really never forgot this
and talked about it
all the time.
And so I thank Dionne
for just being awesome
and all the jams.
She's unbelievable.
And I love you,
Dionne Warwick, so much.
You just made my whole night
and world last night.
So thank you for bringing up
the sweater.
We whipped up a special sweater
just for you, pal.
One of these wretched sweaters.
Check your mailbox 'cause this
guy's coming.
Oh, look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Only you can rock this, Dionne.
Only you could rock
this sweater.
You'll make it look good,
and we love you.
And thanks for thinking about us
and tweeting about us.
Be well, pal. I hope to see you
and talk to you soon.
We have exactly seven shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for 12 days
of Christmas sweaters!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ 12 days
of Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ Seven days left ♪
-That's right! Every show
between now and Christmas,
will be giving
one lucky audience member
a sensational Christmas sweater
from the countdown
to Christmas cabinet.
Since there are
seven shows left,
let's open door number 7.
[ Drum roll ]
Go for it.
All right. Let's look at it.
Beautiful. Oh!
Wow!
That is...
That is something else.
Yeah, literally, I think
it might be something else.
All right. Let's see who's going
home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll,
please?
-Yeah.
[ Drum roll ]
-It is number...
364!
♪♪
-Hey!
Oh, my goodness. Look at this.
Congratulations, you've won
tonight's Christmas sweater.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Jenny, and I'm from Jersey.
-Jenny from Jersey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jenny, would you mind
trying that on for us right now?
Is that okay?
-It's my favorite color.
It really -- Oh, my gosh.
You are going to love this.
There's no right way
to put it on.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, your head can go in
that way.
It doesn't really --
They are sleeves.
That works. Yes.
Oh, this is --
Already I can tell.
Jenny?
Yes, just stop there.
That's perfect.
Jenny, it's almost too --
Yeah, it's perfect!
Look at how beautiful.
Yeah. Look. Lookit!
This is what I'm talking about.
Yeah. Come on, now!
Jenny, look at that.
You should be our model
for all these.
Congratulations.
Thanks again to Jenny,
our lucky audience member.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Bruce Springsteen!
Talking about Jersey?
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪